can chelsea handler sing
[Music]
no hi i'm chelsea handler and today i'm
doing the wired
auto complete interview
okay let's start where did chelsea
handler grow up that's easy new jersey
where does chelsea handler live don't
worry about it
where did chelsea handler go to college
chelsea handler took her sats on acid so
she never got accepted to college
but she had a great time taking that
test
where is chelsea handler's house in
spain oh
well my orca where is chelsea handler
2019 i don't know maybe i disappeared
for that year
where does chelsea handler get her
shirts
from my stylist i think you're talking
about the rock and roll shirts i don't
know where i get them either sorry i
can't be of more help
who is chelsea handler dating i'm single
right now and available and
after seven months of being stuck during
covid
i'm willing to date almost anybody so
i want to open i want to cast my
net a little bit wider than i've been
casting it in previous years
since i need to lock something down soon
because
i'm in decline i mean i have orthotics
now i just got my first pair of reading
glasses at cvs
i shaved my face the other day and also
put on aftershave so
i think that i need to lock something
down quickly in terms of a man
so if you're watching this and you think
yes please contact me
i had a big crush on andrew cuomo when
the pandemic was at its height
in new york city because i liked what he
was bringing to the table
but in reality that's a little bit i
like somebody who can come in
you know like he's like like and just
handle a situation i want somebody to
kind of
manhandle me which isn't a popular thing
to say right now but i like that kind of
old-fashioned
like old men get me my sweet spot is
between 60 and 80 year old men
unfortunately i'm not willing to date
men that age
my ideal guy if i had to pick a
celebrity
i would pick like a jon hamm type but
i'm not really
trying to date a celebrity i would like
a real person who is chelsea handler's
therapist
funny you should mention that my
therapist's name is dan siegel
and um he really helped me
kind of like uncover my own
self-awareness and also
he helped me discover
you know all of my shortcomings my lack
of patience my constant irritation with
people
constantly finding people annoying and
wondering why
and not understanding that everybody
didn't find everybody else annoying
um he is somebody that really helped me
with all of those things
so i owe a lot to him i wrote a book
about him he's in my book life will be
the death of me and i talk about him in
my stand-up special because he really
did help me unlock a lot of my childhood
stuff
and he was he's like kind of famous in
his own right in therapy circles anyway
so um a lot of people do know him and
then after i went to him like five of my
celebrity friends also told me they went
to him so i'm not so special after all
who does chelsea handler look like
martha stewart apparently
oh somebody told me claudia schiffer i
liked that i'm going to do a
side-by-side on instagram with her soon
but i have to get the right angle
because it's obviously not we're not
identical
who else do i look like jenny mccarthy
elizabeth banks
people always get us confused yeah i
think that those are those are my four
main ones i don't get confused with
martha stewart
but i did do a side by side of martha
stewart and me on instagram
and she kind of looked better and
younger so i'm still confused about that
let's go to the next one what
is chelsea handler doing now this
interview what is with chelsea handler
and oranges
my psychiatrist handed me an orange in
one of our sessions and i wrote about it
in my book and it's in my new stand-up
special when he handed me this orange
it was a turning point in our therapy
experience so i look at
orange as kind of like a life raft when
you see somebody who's going through a
troubling time or going through
something difficult
handing them an orange is like a
metaphor for handing them a lifeline so
that's why i like oranges
and i like orange juice also what is
chelsea handler like in real life
a [ __ ] what does chelsea handler look
like
sometimes good and sometimes not so
great
what is chelsea handler's real name
chelsea handler
what does chelsea handler eat not that
much it turns out i'm eating less and
less as i transition into an elderly
woman
i have to be honest i really like liquid
more than i like
food so i love green juices and i love
it's like sparkling waters and i think
i'm
filling up on so much fluid that i have
lost my interest
in food so my food is really plain i eat
like plain turkey i do love chicken
nuggets i've always loved chicken
nuggets and that's never gonna
stop so that will always be um you know
one of my shortcomings
as a 45 year old adult woman
anyway oh another thing i like to eat is
egg whites and this is
something a recipe that i've well i can
only really make it for myself because
no one will eat my food but i like egg
whites in the morning
with i scramble egg whites with avocado
slices
and then i take that old-fashioned kind
of
romano parmesan cheese and just douse
everything in parmesan cheese
so basically i'm eating like a cheese
and avocado
dish with a little bit of egg whites on
the side it's mostly cheese
is evan handler related to chelsea
handler
great question i asked him the same
exact thing
and he's not related to me or so he says
he's an actor
by the way is chelsea handler vegan
no i think vegan people fart a lot and i
have been around them and i've smelled
their farts and i'm not interested in
being vegan because of that although i
am down with being a vegetarian and not
and not eating animals i'm ready to go
in that direction and i think we're all
kind of heading in that direction
whether we want to be or not
is chelsea handler a pharmacist funny
you should mention that i am very
passionate about pharmacology a lot of
my friends depend on me
for pharmacological advice and
intuitiveness i would frame myself as a
pharmacological intuit
not to be confused with a
pharmacological inuit which would be
an alaskan pharmacist i like
i can look at your body and talk to you
for three or four minutes and basically
tell if you're going to be good on
vicodin or if you would prefer xanax or
maybe you'd like an ambien
i know what drugs are going to work for
what people i've helped my sister i've
helped so many people in my family
my personal favorite pharmaceutical and
by the way i'm not a doctor
so don't take it and then blame me for
anything but
doxycycline will knock anything out of
your system
it can knock malaria out of your system
it can get rid of acne
on your face i mean doxycycline twice a
day a cycle of it for 10 days
will get rid of almost anything and i
take one every morning just because i
don't want to [ __ ] around
is chelsea handler related to goldie
hawn sort of
i call her mama g and i
and she says that i'm her daughter i
mean i think she says that to a lot of
people but i'm gonna pretend that she
only says it to me and i am close with
their family their families like i like
to go over there
and be around that whole family i like
their i like the drama
and i like all the different kids from
the different relationships it's like a
little patchwork puzzle
so yeah i like to spend family time with
goldie and kurt
how old is chelsea handler funny you
should mention that
i'm 45 years old so i'm in my
middle life does that sound sexy
how to contact chelsea handler uh
probably instagram i usually try and
message people back on instagram
when i have an inordinate amount of time
i can sit there for hours and write
messages
but that's or twitter i'm on both pretty
frequently
how did chelsea handler meet chewie well
that's a cute story
so when i had the show chelsea lately
they wanted me to have a sidekick
and so they brought in like you know a
bunch of these kind of characters
and when i saw chewie i was like you're
gonna be with me
and we hired him it was one of the most
fruitful relationships of my career i
mean it was like being in a good mood
every time you walked into work because
every time you see his little face come
around the corner with his cute little
outfits and his berets
and you'd go into his dressing room and
they had all his little shoes lined up
and he was just the sweetest little guy
and he was close with his family and he
was close with my family
so i met him on an audition we were
auditioning for sidekicks and i saw him
and i was like forget everybody
else that's the guy so yeah was
chelsea handler in hunger games that was
elizabeth banks
can chelsea handler sing oh
no i can't sing and i can't dance i
blame it on being jewish
but i don't know if that's the real
reason the dancing is the jewish problem
i don't know what the singing problem is
but nobody in my family can sing or
dance and that's why i talk so much
and so often which chelsea handler book
is the best
uh i would say life will be the death of
me
with my last book that was the most
personal that was the most real
that was like post therapy so it's
really raw
uh yeah and that's what i based my new
stand-up special off of my last book
chelsea handler zodiac i am a pisces and
if you're into enneagrams i'm the number
eight which is another thing my
psychiatrist
dan siegel taught me uh about enneagrams
which is a kind of way to like
frame your personality there are nine
numbers and you kind of
figure out which number you are so it's
a really cool way of like uh
learning more about your personality
type without astrology
i went through my astrology phase and
i'm kind of over it you know it just
seems
a little bit silly thank you so much
wired i hope you learned something about
me that you
wanted to and i want to wish everybody
happiness and to find joy in this
kind of confusing time and not to give
up hope to be optimistic
and to be hopeful and uh yeah just try
and stay
strong you know we're all in this
together